One of the unique opportunities you have
in this program is the opportunity to
prepare for your courses in advance.
Most of our classes make all
the materials available at udacity.com.
So if you're not sure if you're ready
for a course, you can preview it there
and decide if you're actually
ready to take that course.
They also provide readiness
questions on the program website.
You can use those to evaluate whether or
not you're ready for the course, and
what you need to brush up on in
order to get ready for the course.
Some classes involve things
like C programming or
linear algebra that you may not
have seen in several years.
So you want to give yourself a chance to
refresh yourself on those things before
you take those courses.
Use the materials available to you to
decide what classes you're ready to take
and what you need to do to get ready for
those classes.